as the most interesting man in the world
Jonathan Goldsmith was a ubiquitous
presence on TV screens for nearly a
decade then just like that he was gone
so what ever happened to him most people
are probably more familiar with the most
interesting man in the world character
than with the actor who plays him
Jonathan Goldsmith Goldsmith had to
audition for the role in the do Eis
advertising campaign along with hundreds
of other contenders the actor told
primer magazine that the producers of
the campaign were looking for someone
young and Latino however Goldsmith was a
Jewish man in his late 60s potential
candidates were given a line of dialogue
about arm wrestling Fidel Castro and
were asked to invent a story around it
so for 30 minutes Goldsmith improvised
about various exotic escapades he told
NPR that he based his version of the
character on his late friend Fernando
llamas llamas was like Goldsmith a
fellow actor and sailor Goldsmith
thought he could do an homage to llas
that would fit the bill the casting
director loved the performance but
thought he was too old for the part
thankfully his agent stepped in to argue
on his behalf reasoning that the most
interesting man in the world had to have
life experience gold smith got the call
that he'd been cast shortly thereafter
doeki sales skyrocketed after the
character's debut while Goldsmith became
one of the highest paid commercial
actors in the world Goldsmith played the
most interesting man in the world for 10
years if he were to punch you in the
face you would have to fight off the
strong urge to thank him but in 2016
dokis decided to go in a different
direction and produced One Last
commercial starring the actor his
sendoff saw him saying goodbye to Earth
and many of its dignitaries as he
embarked on a one-way trip to Mars dokis
attempted to reboot the campaign with a
new actor in the role Austine lron the
company worried that Goldsmith's
character wasn't targeted to a
millennial audience whose tastes trended
toward craft brw rather than
mass-produced products Goldsmith was in
his late 7s when his tenure with dokis
expired while lron was in his mid-40s
the second iteration never really took
off and by 2018 dois had transitioned to
merely using the phrase stay interesting
in its marketing efforts but gold smith
had elevated both the Brand's status and
his own in the decade prior he was as
hot a commodity as he'd ever been while
his most interesting man in the world
remains one of the longest running TV
commercial characters ever alongside Flo
from Progressive and the Verizon test
man can you hear me
now good after Jonathan Goldsmith's time
with dokis came to a close he was
approached by another Brewer Stella
Artois to co-star in a Super Bowl
commercial Goldsmith agreed in the ad
which aired in 2019 the most interesting
man in the world notices that the dude
from the big Labowski orders a Stella
Artois instead of his signature white
russian the do the binds sadly
Goldsmith's collaboration with Stella
Artois was a one-time Affair however
astal tequila wanted a more permanent
relationship with the actor when they
scooped him up in 2017 once again again
Goldsmith played The Classy character
he' created for his previous employer
this time however the campaign riffed on
the idea that the most interesting man
in the world has said that he didn't
always drink beer this calls for tequila
Goldsmith signed on for a series of 10
commercials with astral tequila they
didn't become as mem worthy as his
original appearances for dokis had but
they were still a smart move on the part
of the smaller scale liquor maker
Goldsmith didn't start out as a
commercial actor in fact he has hundreds
of appearances across television and
film after moving to Los Angeles as a
young man he worked various odd jobs to
support himself while pursuing his dream
eventually he found work on procedurals
like Perry Mason Goldsmith often
appeared as an extra or guest star and
prior to the doeki ad campaign his
steadiest work came on shows like
Gunsmoke gold smith was already well
past the average retirement age when he
stepped back from being the most
interesting man in the world but he
continued to work on screen in 2018 he
was in mam Mia here we go again then in
2023 he guest starred on gry's Anatomy
Goldsmith will always be associated with
the character he embodied for dois but
he's been a part of so many classic
films TV shows and franchises that
audiences are likely to see his face
again whenever they revisit old
favorites it stands to reason that the
most interesting man in the world would
have a lot of great stories to tell
perhaps it's no surprise then that
Jonathan Goldsmith penned a memoir
called stay interesting the Memoir hit
bookshelves in the summer of 2017 the
title and the subtitle I don't always
tell stories about my life but when I do
they're true and amazing poke fun at the
slogans uttered by his doi's character
the book however is full of foul
language and salacious anecdotes it
seems the young Goldsmith was
interesting in an entirely different way
than the refined but mysterious
gentleman he pretended to be in beer
commercials stay interesting deals
mostly with Goldsmith's life before he
found Fame he's candid about his
failures as an actor his bad behavior
and his many Affairs he refers to
himself as as naughty and unmanageable
as a child and includes the tale of how
he lost his virginity in high school to
a sex worker Goldsmith also detailed how
he regularly picked up wannabe actresses
who waited around bars for the likes of
Marquee actors like Warren batty
furthermore he also names names when
discussing his sexual exploits
Goldsmith's Memoir is grittier than some
might expect but it's also meant to be
inspirational despite the more todger
details his story is one about
overcoming obstacles relentlessly
pursuing Ambitions and enjoying life's
journey and I guess the whole theme of
the book is perseverance and not to let
anybody else right your legacy Goldsmith
made the most of his time in the
spotlight and often promoted his
interesting life on social media even
after his doi's commercial ceased to
play on TV the actor began using social
media around 2016 under accounts that
referenced the character he portrayed he
even frequently used the hashtag stay
interesting gold smith has a fairly
active Pres presence on social media he
posts status updates in which he shares
the interesting things he is doing
sometimes he uploads photographs and
stills of himself as a younger actor
sometimes he participates in memes for
example on April 8th 2023 he got in on
the viral trend of turning himself into
a Barbie character poster Goldsmith also
uses his social media platforms to
encourage his fans to check out his
previous work contribute to various
Charities and to vote on April 28th 2023
he posted a reminder to his followers is
that to have a life well- lived they
must be well read the accompanying photo
shot from behind his head shows him
reading an unknown book Goldsmith has
admitted that he wasn't always a model
citizen especially when times were tough
but he has always had a soft spot for
those in need once he had the notoriety
and resources the journeyman actor used
his celebrity and Fortune to advocate
for various causes a lifelong lover of
animals Goldsmith has been involved with
Charities devoted to both wildlife and
pets since before he became famous he's
volunteered for organizations that help
protect the endangered Siberian tiger
and work to cure cancer in dogs but as
he told edible Vermont Goldsmith's most
proud of his efforts aimed at improving
life for kids among his various
charitable efforts Goldsmith supports
free arts for abused children a program
designed to enrich artistic skills and
emotional health in kids who've suffered
from trauma he's also an Arts educator
and advocate for the global teaching
project an organization that provides
rural schools with access to experts and
resources additionally Goldsmith was the
state chairperson for the make A- Wish
Foundation an organization he's worked
with for more than 10 years Goldsmith
also gives his time and attention to
programs like the Los Angeles Mission
where he served dinner on Christmas Eve
and hunger-free Vermont a group that
provides free hot lunches to students
he's even collaborated with the Nobel
prize winning Minds Advisory Group which
works to clear landmines from former War
zones being handsome especially in one's
golden year years and having a cool job
undoubtedly makes someone interesting
looks very cool why I'm but in order to
be considered the most interesting man
in the world you'll need a resume full
of captivating abilities and
extracurriculars thankfully Goldsmith
has all of that and then some in his 85
years Goldsmith has dabbled in just
about every possible Pastime by his own
account he's an avid sailor and
fisherman he's also a confident Gardener
and home cook his go-to meal is
spaghetti carbonara in an interview with
edible Vermont Goldsmith shared that he
and his wife host cocktail hours during
which he serves drinks in his mother's
Waterford Crystal he also loves to read
and has even dabbled in writing poetry
having famous friends is another part of
being an interesting person so it
shouldn't be any surprise that Goldsmith
is friendly with none other than the
44th President of the United States
Barack Obama the two had first met
during the then president's visit to
Vermont after that initial meeting
Goldsmith was invited to be a surprise
guest of honor at Obama's 50th birthday
celebr ation according to Politico the
two chatted over cigars and hid it off
they even saw each other two more times
during one visit the former commander-in
Chief even gifted Goldsmith a pair of
gold cufflinks bearing the presidential
[Music]
seal